I miss that the universe and it's nice
to get to go back Diego Luna dishing to
et about reprising his robe won a Star
Wars story role of Cassie and and or in
a new live-action series what was your
reaction when he found out you were
getting your own series I was very happy
I was very happy it's a dream come true
it means that universe you know and now
I'm back it's fantastic you're really
doing this I want to help I'm thrilled
it's gonna be amazing I already know I'm
gonna have a great time because I know
that people I worked with and they're
fantastic and very talented and it's an
amazing team ET sat down with the actor
to talk about his role on Netflix is
drama
narcos Mexico which tells the story of
Mexican drug lord
Miguel félix Gallardo and undercover DEA
agent Kiki Camarena so you are playing a
real person someone who is alive behind
bars what kind of head space do you have
to get into to play that role well I
have to forget about the present and
think about the past you know there was
a lot of information for me and I had to
stop one day and say okay this is it now
I'm gonna I'm gonna do my own
interpretation of this and for me the
most important thing was to recreate
that Mexico the Mexico of the eighties
the Mexico I saw as a kid and the Mexico
were where the story happens you know
were you a fan of narcos before you join
the cast I was a fan of the first season
but I didn't follow the second and third
I have two kids yeah but when I got
offered the role I went back and I saw
it again going with a complete new cast
a new story new country it even looks
different you know
to me it looks more cinematic I think I
think they they did something very smart
which is make sure audiences get
surprised you know okay
shocked by by some something they they
might think they know how is it gonna
look and where is it going but they
don't and that's that's interesting and
I bought move
[Music]